[Music]
when it comes to glamour and beauty
celebrities have it down pat but what's
underneath all that makeup today we're
checking out ariana grande Kim
Kardashian Nicki Minaj and many more
celebrities who look totally different
without makeup on don't forget to hit
that notification belt and never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out celebs without
makeup
Dov Cameron let's start with our
absolute fave Doug Cameron is one of the
fastest rising stars and most known for
her main role in Liv and Maddie but for
the past few years the focus has been on
her amazing appearance as mal on
Disney's descendants we absolutely loved
up with or without makeup but check out
this picture of her without any makeup
whatsoever do you even recognize that
it's actually Doug she's usually
sporting amazing smokey eyes so it's
extremely refreshing to see her without
any makeup at all she looks so cute just
chilling at home we can't get over her
look Nicki Minaj it's everyone's
favorite fierce rap diva who is a force
to be reckoned with it's very rare to
catch Nicki without makeup but we
managed to find this photo ever her skin
looks amazing
but if we're completely honest we
probably wouldn't be able to recognize
her without all that heavy makeup Nicki
normally loves her heavy eyeliner and
who can blame her she totally rocks it
but her no makeup look is quite stunning
we'd love to see more of her own natural
look but in the meantime we'll happily
cheer on all her fierce red carpet looks
Demi Lovato Demi Lovato knows how to
rock red carpet events show awards and
concerts but have you ever seen her out
of the spotlight
without all the makeup we've seen Demi
get raw with her emotions before but
she's rarely caught without wearing any
makeup so this is a real treat
check her out like many celebrities
dummy has perfect skin do you think
you'd be able to recognize this face if
she came up to you in public she could
totally pass for just a regular girl
next door except this girl next door can
really belt out a song and make you cry
like no one
all while looking absolutely gorgeous
kendall Jenner we rarely talk about the
Kardashians on the things and we're too
excited that we can finally do that now
have you ever seen kendall Jenner
without makeup it's amazing how
different she looks without it but
definitely still just it's gorgeous
take a look we're not really sure we'd
be able to recognize her if we start at
the gym and her workout clothes either
way we are super jealous of her skin and
her eyebrows very much on point after
all it takes a lot of style to rock that
Kardashian look Kim Kardashian
speaking of Kardashian's you know we
have to mention the one and only Kim
Kardashian is probably the most
talked-about member of the Kardashian
clan she always looks beautiful no
matter what but have you seen her in her
natural beauty well here she is just as
stunning as ever and we have to admit
that we'd probably have to do a double
take to actually recognize her if a
makeup less Kim Kardashian walk down the
street the magic of makeup is truly
amazing
but these celebrities clearly look just
as good without it Mila Kunis although
Mila Kunis has pretty much settled down
into her role as a mother and into her
marriage with the one and only Ashton
Kutcher we have to admit that she's one
of the most beautiful Hollywood
actresses ever but have you ever seen
the image of her without any makeup
it proves that celebrities are just like
us and they don't wear heavy makeup all
day every day and we're sure Muller
spends even less time in makeup now as a
busy mother
we love Neela's completely natural look
it definitely highlights how beautiful
her eyes are with or without makeup
tanomo jo okay we have to talk about the
one the only youtuber tanomo jo she's
probably been talked about more than any
other in the past month
tanomo jo is a controversial youtuber
that loves to share her life stories and
entertain a crowd of more than three
million subscribers we always see her
with a lot of makeup so now we want to
see her without and here she is
once she wipes away all of the
foundation and heavy eyeliner you can
barely tell that this is the same
youtuber you see on screen in one of her
videos Tana also guides you through her
entire makeup process from start to
finish
Courtney act and now it's time to talk
about one of our favorite subjects drag
queens let's be honest drag queens are
magicians when it comes to makeup but no
one is as good as the one and only
Courtney act we've seen Courtney with
and without makeup plenty of times
but we're still shook each time we see
this incredible transformation
Courtney's real name is Shane and is
just as gorgeous with or without makeup
but let's be honest the drag queen magic
is pretty incredible
do you have what it takes to recognize a
drag queen without her drag on Willam
belli now let's not forget about this
Queen the sassy Willam belli is
definitely an icon in the drag world and
we're still so obsessed with his
transformation hands up if you take a
makeup lesson from a drag queen these
divas are seriously pros here's what
Willam looks like underneath all that
makeup unless you know your drag queens
there's no way you'd be able to
recognize willow Mountain about the
power of makeup is truly fascinating to
be completely honest we're starting to
get really jealous some of us can barely
wing our eyeliner correctly Cl
this one's for all our kpop fans out
there CL is a well-known kpop star on a
mission to break through the American
market she was once a part of a very
popular girl group called 21 and has
since then been working on her solo
projects CL can usually be seen wearing
tons of makeup and we really love her
smoky eye look with heavy eyelashes but
here's how she looks totally natural
quite the difference isn't it she's
definitely still just as gorgeous if not
even more adorable without makeup Emilia
Clarke just wait until your jaw falls on
the floor after you see a picture of
Emilia Clarke without any makeup Emilia
is a popular British actress most known
for her role in the Game of Thrones but
when she strips down all that makeup she
looks even more beautiful than before
check her out how can someone be this
gorgeous it's hard to believe this is
the same face we see in her Daenerys
attire
looks totally different and almost
unrecognizable do you think you'd
recognize Emilia if she walked down the
street without any makeup
Adele okay girl we see your eyebrows and
they're definitely on fleek this is what
Adele looks like without makeup
adele is usually the queen of contour
and heavy eyeliner but over the years
she's been seen in a slightly different
light and she looks totally normal
remember when Adele herself posed as
Adele in front of Adele impersonators
she has a signature look it feels
strange to see her with no makeup on you
for sure wouldn't be able to spot her if
you saw her outside of her diva attire
and makeup that is of course until she
starts singing Alicia Keys Alicia Keys
is absolutely gorgeous we can all agree
on that
in recent years the actress and
recording artist stopped wearing makeup
altogether she doesn't wear it to events
red carpets or anything else and she's
still absolutely glowing it took a while
for the crowd to get adjusted to no
makeup Alicia but she explained that
makeup is completely unnecessary and
women should feel empowered with or
without it and we definitely agree as
you can see from all these celebrities
that are clearly rocking the makeup free
look even if they're caught off guard
well done Alicia Ariana Grande Ariana
Grande is known as the little diva that
always gets glammed up we're talking big
heavy eyeliner and even bigger lashes
that accompany her dangerous woman look
but underneath all that she's just an
adorable little cutie it's rare to see
Ariana without any makeup but these
pictures just prove how adorable celebs
look in their natural habitat until she
opens her mouth and sings there's no way
you'd be able to recognize makeup free
Ariana we just can't get over how
adorable she looks Christina Aguilera
speaking of divas who can possibly
forget about the one and only Christina
Aguilera 90s kids remember Christina in
heavy makeup big hair and a lot of
attitude but kids today might know
Christina from this photo shoot where
she completely showed off her natural
look and it is nothing like we've ever
seen before
of course you'd be able to recognize her
voice just about anywhere but could you
recognize her it's
use the pun stripped she looks nothing
like the Christina Aguilera we know from
Lady Marmalade or any of her previous
old-school eras still though just as
flawless Katy Perry if you look for
pictures of Katy Perry without makeup
online you'll come across plenty but you
could relate to because let's be honest
Katy Perry without makeup is our mood in
real life Katy is known for her
eccentric makeup and all-over style so
to see her makeup wiped off feels a bit
surreal
we love this side of Katy although to be
completely honest she does look pretty
much unrecognizable but seriously Katy
Perry without makeup is pretty much a
meme and a consistent mood she's such an
icon and we love her so much
whether she's got her makeup face on or
not Lady Gaga speaking of eccentric
makeup one person that looks completely
different without any makeup is
definitely Lady Gaga over the years
we've seen plenty of images of Lady gaga
with a completely natural look and we're
still amazed it's hard to believe this
is even her but it absolutely is and she
looks totally gorgeous without makeup -
have you noticed that most celebrities
have an acne free skin totally unfair um
can you hang on just a sec just off to
find a way to have skin as perfect as
Lady Gaga's BRB it's even unusual seeing
her with her hair down Marilyn Manson we
have to talk about Marilyn Manson he's
most known for that scary goth look it
was pretty controversial at the time his
makeup is key to his onstage persona but
when the makeup comes off the real
Marilyn Manson is quite different first
of all Marilyn Manson isn't even his
name without the makeup he's Bryan Hugh
Warner check him out sure he's still
wearing a bit of eyeliner but his look
is definitely stripped down and not what
we're used to
there is no question we'd never be able
to recognize him without the heavy smoky
eyes and the Turk lipstick you have to
admit that a stage persona has quite an
impressive look to him RuPaul's
covergirl put the face in your walk we
mention Courtney act and Willam Bell and
they both start on the one and only
RuPaul
drag race created by the drag icon
herself we're mostly used to seeing
RuPaul in drag and we're not used to
seeing this divas makeup free look at
all he'd definitely sashay away from our
minds if we saw him in real life we
would never think that he's the RuPaul
everyone knows and loves that is of
course until you hear him talk and then
we're pretty sure everyone would know
who's walking that walk and talking not
talk when G and last but not least it's
the popular Australian youtuber who's
taking over the world with her clever
life hacks her YouTube channel has an
impressive 11 million subscribers and
she'll win you over with her adorable
looks when G herself made a video
explaining how the power of makeup can
practically transform you into another
person and her makeup free look is
totally unreal she looks absolutely
adorable but we have to admit that it
takes a lot of skill and practice to
perfect the wengie look she looks
shockingly different without it but
still just as beautiful and that's it
for our video do you prefer wearing
makeup or no makeup let us know in the
comments thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]